good afternoon and welcome to this
Friday's edition of the Friday app
clinic
my name is rater I'm joined today in the
studio by Adam and our us well producer
in hi I'm in the Lewis and I'm gigantic
and today we're going to take a look at
music playing apps so these are all apps
which you guys have nominated in the
moderator queue and we're gonna take a
look at the top five or six depending on
how many we can get through in the next
45 minutes so let's have a look at the
apps that we're going to check out today
so this is the list at least it was very
briefly and there it is again so I'm
gonna take a look at two nawicki well
these are all backwards on my monitor so
I'm gonna look them over here we can
look at toon wiki xenoamp then we're
gonna check out Spotify uber hi
presenter amp power ant xenoamp and play
a pro so absolutely there was there was
a little bit of suspicious voting
patterns apparent in the moderator this
week there's a massive amount of
enthusiasm for xenoamp
absolutely and I personally look forward
to having a very close look at designer
app before we do let's have a look at
our top tips for what every good music
playing app should have so this is the
music player must-haves these are the
things which are which we're really
looking for is as a fundamental to what
we think makes a really good music
playing experience so the first one is
it must play music
now that would surprise me retail that
seems like a really really stiff piece
of advice there I I know you'd be
difficult for many music players if we
try and set a low bar that we think most
people can achieve and I realize that
this means maybe pushing that a little
bit high but we'll see we'll see I think
most of the apps should should possibly
be able to to match that we won't
actually be able to tell though will we
because of the man that's right the man
will not let us play a copyrighted music
on air so you'll just have to take our
word for whether or not it's playing
back indeed and in fact that's why we
have Ian
on camera he is going to be singing all
of the music tracks as they come through
to his headsets you know in Milan I hope
you cued up a lot of Lady Gaga and so
the way we did use your phone so you
know whatever's there isn't what if you
get perfect what else we got on that
list so we weren't rooting through them
all we'll just leave them up there for
you guys to to check out but it's things
like you know we're really looking for
that polished experience so we're
looking for things like the ability to
control playback over the lock screen
through notifications sensible things
like using audio focus and muting when
we disconnect headphones all those sorts
of things so we've actually gone through
and tested all of these apps for each of
these things so we will mention - even
if we don't necessarily go through and
try each piece for each at serious side
of that let's get started perfect so
we're gonna start off with a tune wiki
which was by far and away the most
popular of the votes in fact had zero
down votes which some would consider
suspicious and I just think is an
indication of people's enthusiasm for an
awesome app - it has been around on Play
Store and before Android Market for
quite some time
absolutely yeah it's a popular app so
why don't we let's fire it up on the
tablet so we can get the nice high
resolution graphics and see what it
looks like alright so the first thing
that I think we noticed when we started
this up is that it takes an age to load
now transformer prime is actually a
pretty powerful piece of hardware and
that still took like three or four
seconds I was a little freaky yeah I
think we may need too much power he's
too quickly yeah so even the load time
that we noticed just now I think that
this was probably a little bit quicker
than the first launch was that we tried
earlier there's more sex show me show me
yeah see if we can bring up the the
phone cam and we'll see I see how long
it takes on that one
starting now yeah two three four so
again that was probably quicker than the
very first time we load it up but that's
still a good sort of for second load to
to bring the first graphics up now that
may have been influenced by the
advertising in the app as well in the
free version that's very possible so
that's something to keep in mind is that
you really want to have that initial
load time to be as quick as you can to
the developers so that I should say
users don't feel like the app is frozen
that's that that's kind of a killer
killer move right away so okay so let's
let's start have a bit of a navigation
so I think the first place you want to
go is my music right so let's see how
that looks so we can see the the in
terms of a tablet layout and this part
hasn't been particularly optimized we
have that sort of telltale really wide
ListView sort of effect you know which
can be okay it can be a little bit
off-putting I think if you've got lots
of black screen space or white screen
real estate that can be a bit of a
negative but generally speaking I think
it kind of works
yeah so they have used the action bar
you can tell visually that they've used
a viewpager with the pager title strip
style here so we have an instant
indication that if we swipe left and
right that we're going to get to some
different content in the application
very nice we've got the standard sort of
standard looking action bar it doesn't
look quite right is it slightly higher
than it should be well it looks like on
the tablet it's about the right size but
on the phone it seems to be slightly
oversized hmm okay yeah I'm looking at
them both in front of me so that's
interesting
all right let's let's play a song once
that's actually would you mind putting
putting the phone up there Daniel
yeah we can see what what I was talking
about I'm sure
well Daniel is doing that I just want to
remind everybody that I'm watching the
the live stream right now on YouTube so
if you have any questions that you want
to pass along to you right to Adam
go ahead and type them in there and
that's where we're watching we're not
watching on the Google+ stream because I
can only do one thing at a time all
right go ahead guys all right thanks man
and we should definitely consider you
know we should have cared something in
reserve executive producer should have
been the credit you get when you can't
do two things at once but in the
meantime so let's have a look so you
reckon this is slightly too tall can you
talk us through how can you tell or he
just like Roman and able to spot to
pixel differences just through bra I
it's mostly that nice in this case it's
mostly a matter of sort of visually
measuring against some of the other
elements on the screen but the real
telltale thing in this UI in particular
is if you check the size of the touch
highlight that sits there you notice
that the button itself that touch target
is slightly smaller than the full bar
now that's not a bad thing on its own
but it does sort of reveal the
difference here yeah okay so that's nice
I mean while we're looking at the at the
action bar as well I'd point out you've
kind of got the Settings menu here as
well which again isn't a standard
preference to screen you can tell from
these right carrots or Chevron's which
are non-standard
so that that's obviously custom it it
looks relatively standard so it's not
too bad but it would be kind of nice
there's no real reason not to go with
the standard no preferences screen here
so it'd be kind of nice if you guys did
if we go back and can you can you touch
one of those I'm really curious why
people use the the right carrot I have
my own theories but usually it's just to
indicate that there's another screen
underneath it that's going to take you
someplace different I think I think
that's true but why in particular the
right carrot because the the the action
for going to another screen has nothing
to do with anything to the right of what
you see right so and I and I guess what
I'm implying is that maybe that's a
carryover from you know some other type
of system that we're where the animation
is different yeah it feels that way like
is there maybe the developers who have
used a different operating system which
perhaps when you hit right everything
slides from left to right so that you
canceling system like Gingerbread
possibly possibly a different operating
system like do like gingerbread so one
of the other ones here as well is the
design guide I believe it explicitly
calls out the case of settings is
something that shouldn't be either
frequent important or typical so
realistically that should be in an
overflow but it's exactly understandable
in a case like this where if that's the
only option that would be in the
overflow
then there's sort of a simple judgment
call to be made there yeah I agree I
think in this case though I mean what
you've got here is you know if nothing
else is just taking up more screen real
estate or something else that the user
has to look at and understand like you
see a cog in your like what is the cog
mean which means you need to press it to
find out and I think just having that
overflow menu is kind of where users are
already expecting things like settings
to be so it makes it sort of cognitively
easier to understand what you're
supposed to do it because and again this
is something that I tend to go on a bit
at length but it's creating that magical
experience where as soon as you launch
the app you should be doing whatever it
is that the app is designed to do
straight away so you shouldn't have to
spend time exploring the app and
figuring out how it all works and in
order to understand its value like
people are going to install this start
using it and a little less they have to
think about how things work it's kind of
the more of a magical experience it is
for those people that's definitely true
but what you need to watch out for as
well and I think that what
developers look at when they make
decisions such as this is what do you do
a lot of developers will count clicks
mm-hmm in terms of how deep in action is
or how complex the process for getting
to a particular action is and I think in
this case the decision was made okay
one click is better than two hmm so but
that's not always the only metric that
you should use when deciding on UI
elements such as this yeah I think what
you were saying earlier is kind of the
key there it's you want to make it
really quick and easy to do the things
that are most important for your app and
anything which you don't want people to
do all the time can afford to live
further away in fact we had this
discussion when we were looking at this
app earlier today around the my profile
button we go can I kind of in for just a
second
you can several people are mentioning
that Adams far too quiet
oh yeah so you might be coming when I go
when I'm talking possibly it might also
be the the mic volume and also just just
project Adam just project I think you've
got still got half a shot of whiskey
there you might want to do okay all
right thanks a lot
now we have loud Adam hopefuls have to
go well possibly I should just be more
quiet and we can just adjust all the
gain up I think that would be a terrible
idea I think you guys should be like our
boss when we're in a teleconference and
and he starts like shouting at the
people across the room I think that's
how you should think of yourself right
now we can do that project shout at the
user shot at the users when the
developers wow there's so many of us
on-screen there um okay so we like we
were saying we had this exact discussion
about my profile and let's look at that
first and we'll go on to the terms of
will play music next because I'm sure
you know we need to keep something there
as a suspense for I users doesn't play
music so my uncle was that my profile
seemed like the sort of thing that
should go on the overflow menu it's like
how often are you gonna change it any
sort of social networking you do your
profile once and you're kind of done you
disagree and
Tom we hadn't logged in so that's true
thought to say so I thought that there
was especially a defense for an app like
this that aims to make your music a bit
more social a bit more of a connected
experience so I thought that this isn't
reflected on where they want to just
have to go hmm
so basically we're saying if if the
whole point is to try and make it more
of a social song experience that it kind
of makes sense to have that social media
stuff front and center right so if we
and if in fact if we go in we can see
that it really is it's more than just
you know who are you and what's your
current status you can have personal
messages list your top songs top artists
so it's really stuff which is going to
change when almost a daily basis right
so I guess in summary we're saying yeah
fair enough you know and they've got all
of this so this basically my profile is
just a way into this to the more social
experience of the app though I have to
say that the the styling of this section
could do with a something of a revamp
feels a little old feels a little you
know staticky absolute layout he almost
well it is using the holo style buttons
and such but I think that it's it sort
of forms this grid of grey that's a
little bit difficult to visually get
away from and that some icons are some
other splashes of color on this screen
could really lighten things up a little
bit how this is the thing like I spent
entirely too much of my life before
joining Android writing applications in
c-sharp net for you know financial
organizations so I've seen far too many
of these screens which are just ranges
of gray buttons on why the gray
backgrounds so you know maybe it's just
a hindbrain thing that just sets me off
but that's entirely fair yeah I'd like
it to look a little bit prettier
particularly considering that the rest
of the app is is styled like you've
obviously got a designer here creating
these you know very strong visual
graphics and so it'd be great to see
that sort of promoted throughout the
entire app do we wanna have a look to
see if plays any music
we ready for a little bit daring I I
know but at some point we're gonna have
to run these apps really through their
paces let's give it a shot let's have a
look so let's take a look at our music
so we jump into what's at this point a
fairly standard list of tracks we
noticed that again the viewpager title
indicator gives us simple indication of
some of the other functions that exist
just off screen we have a streaming
radio built in via shoutcast
this is really nice and this is
something that Manian actually called
out for podcast players that we would
like to see a media player which has
both live you know our own audio that we
can listen to and also having sort of
live streaming radio type functionality
so this is a big plus for me it sort of
takes account to different kinds of app
in one place absolutely I have to say
though I found it a little bit hidden
because if we go back to the main menu
it's my music right so I'm expecting
this is where I go to listen to things
that are already in my library and it's
not until this my computer yeah 90s feel
to it in that case exactly and really
what we're just saying is music so it
would be much nicer there and being able
to have the sort of the streaming stuff
more readily available and readily
apparent I think would be a real plus
right so next we get into some of the
things on the library screen here the
shuffle all show all songs and show all
albums elements here are some really
tiny touch targets hmm I mean these
things are probably under 40 dip tall
generally we try and go at least 48 in
both dimensions to get a nice happy
touch target absolutely yeah so it'd be
nice if those were a little bit bigger I
definitely see wanting to break it up
and still show a little bit more of the
content mmm still separated out from the
songs themselves a little bit yeah but I
think that the icons and some other
styling could be used to help with that
as well yeah absolutely I mean this is a
few options you've got here personally
I'd like to see this is sort of you know
three touch targets all a bit bigger
with sort of icons with text underneath
or something along those lines but
something certainly easier to touch
every time someone tries to touch
something and feels like they're going
to miss or it touches the wrong thing
it's kind of a bad experience for your
users so you want to you know avoid that
if at all
all right all right I love it let's have
a look
songs and albums so again we go through
here we've got the the album covers at
this point along with the the names and
everything else we've got right touches
I got on the end to this yes so this was
something that stood out as we were
testing as well we have the secondary
touch targets along these list items a
very similar to what Google Play Music
has but you'll notice that these don't
actually have any sort of a pressed
highlight that's readily visible or if
it does it's very very subtle so again
that's just one of those small polish
type of elements but it is responsive I
haven't actually managed to miss that
touch target yeah so it looks like it's
the right size he just don't know that
you're touching it right it'd be nice to
see a little bit more of a visual
confirmation of that as well
now it's also worth noting as well but
you know we almost have sort of a
contradiction in styles here we're in
that in the config menu we've got the
the right-facing caret and here we've
got the sort of the bottom right corner
caret indicating a drop down menu and I
think it's probably clear to most users
how those are different but it kind of
highlights the fact that in Android
generally speaking clicking on something
means navigate to they will perform that
action and anything else you've got on
the bottom right is sort of been in
place
you know context menu if you will that's
true ah so should we actually try and
play some music let's try it yeah let's
make sure that the volume controls work
so this is good so we're actually
adjusting the the volume control of the
media stream rather than the ringer
because even though we're not playing
music so that's that's important I'm
gonna mute dance of it the man doesn't
get us well it's always great to make
sure that you can adjust that volume
before you actually start playing just
to get blasted by music the second they
hit the play button that's exactly right
we'll miss the start if the audio is too
low also just as bad
okay which which title which looks you
know kind of like an innuendo should we
go with well I love it and he's large or
it's not big it's large let's go with
that and his large BAM and of course
that's what you were all thinking
okay so again we've navigated down into
the album so now we go through the song
and it all works
so it's instrumental so you can see here
kind of I think one of the the key
selling points of tune wiki is that it
will allow you to view the lyrics for
songs if they happen to be in the
library and not only that but it follows
a very karaoke style scrolling mechanism
for each line of the song so that as the
song plays it Scrolls forward and if I
can find one let's see you might even
have more likelihood of having the
lyrics for so you can see that the
lyrics are loading up it gets a that's
been pulled you can see that as it's
sort of pulling down making that request
it got a little flashy in that box it
feels like you could probably do all of
that stuff like do all over cashing the
checking do that offline before you
start updating UI so that you kind of
get away from that you know things
flashing that's true especially when you
have a local music library that's not
going to change terribly often or when
it's actually you know that your reindex
saying that you have some new content
absolutely so here you can see exactly
what we're talking about you'll slowly
eventually start to see the lyrics news
as the song continues to play in did you
want to sing along for us no I I don't
sing The Clash ah make sure to check to
this beforehand otherwise you know it
works pretty well the one thing which
you may want to be a little bit cautious
of and I think it's okay in this app
there just a general piece of advice
you've got some pretty small touch
targets along the bottom to control the
music playback right next to the app now
there are some ad policies around making
sure that you don't have action targets
where they could accidentally result in
an ad click I think the general way that
music players are constructed is there
is an expectation that that's where the
playback controls will be but you know
just it's something definitely to be
cautious of here particularly because
these are all a little bit small
particularly when you get to things like
random and and repeat they're you know
the icons themselves are quite little
and immediately next to the ad right and
keep in mind that it doesn't necessarily
matter how large the icon is it matters
how large the touch target itself is how
easy is it to really miss mmm so as you
can see as we go into press this once
again this is actually fairly small but
it is separated out from the ad as well
so I think that in terms of being close
to the ad that's not too much of a
problem in terms of being too close to
the ad that's too much that's not much
of a problem but it might be a little
bit easy to miss those depending on yeah
depending on how you're using it and
helping you fingers off so we can scroll
along here so food while we're listening
to particular artists you can see we've
got more information about the group
there's this whole community aspect that
we talked about beforehand so you can
see other people who have shared this
music or are fans of the clash so this
is where it gets a little bit
interesting so we again we discussed
this a little bit beforehand but
basically all of the sharing options
that you have within the app are tightly
bound to Facebook and Twitter now
they're probably two of the most popular
mechanisms for social sharing but then
they're not the only ones and as it
happens on this phone we have neither of
these apps installed because we want to
share things other ways and so you know
you've got basically this this app which
you want people to promote for you and I
can't promote them on G+ I can't promote
them via email or anything else because
I can only use these two things so we
would really like to see you sort of
using a more standard share intent so
the send intent so that any app that
I've got on the device that I can use
sharing can be
to get this information out there right
and just because you use this just
because we recommend the scene or at
Android sharing doesn't mean that you
can't do some deeper integration with
some of these I'm a custody case but in
the case of this app if you go to the
specific share action that's here we get
something that once again is very very
tailored to these two networks such that
it's not actually possible to share any
other way hmm
either that or we missed that
functionality zone well and if we missed
it it's kind of - buried and that's kind
of the key right you want to make it
something which people can get to so
we've got the over flaminia that's all
right - no Shanna scroll back to this
song so it continues to pull out some of
the other features that they included in
the overflow menu here that are kind of
interesting they do have some really
convenient things like keep screen on
again this could be useful for the
karaoke absolutely garrix you've got set
as ringtone which is always convenient
so you've got start a sleep timer so in
case you have a long playlist that you
want to shut off after a while
nice it's a fairly feature full out
absolutely and I think that's something
which we definitely decided when we were
looking at this is that you know as far
as music playing apps go this has kind
of everything you could ask for most of
what we're pointing out here is
relatively minor UI tweaks sort of
things which you can do to make the app
a little bit cleaner a little bit more
polished but that's right overall we're
really really happy with this I think
this is a great example
so let's you know check out a couple
more things so we're playing audio at
the moment if we turn on turn off try
that again so unfortunately no lock
screen controls so this kind of sucks
because for me a big use case for me
listening to audio is while I'm driving
and so I want to be able to get to those
controls really quickly and easily
without having to look at my phone at
all like I'll only of course be doing
this one I've stopped but even still I
don't want to play with my phone unlock
it I have a pin unlock you know all
those sorts of things it just makes it
more tiresome I just want to be able to
unlock oh well to turn on screen and hit
skip basically and for it to do its
thing if we look in the notification we
have the notification there so it's here
we don't have the controls in the
notification either which again is a bit
painful means I need to navigate into
yeah in order to be able to control it
and we also see it hasn't actually
navigated me to directly to the to the
lyrics page but I guess there's no need
writing anything on anything here which
lets me hit pause is probably sufficient
right we also have what seems to be a
bit of a legacy froyo style notification
icon in the status bar here as well with
the gradient frame around it yeah cool
should we have a corner at the playback
on the tablet as well as curious to see
whether the experience on tablet sort of
lives up to be - the phone version yeah
you're going over to that one let me
break in for just a second there's a
couple things that I oh there's two of
you
the couple things that I wanted to bring
up first
that apparently toon wiki is a massively
complex program that deserves its own
hour of work because you're still
talking about it half an hour after the
show has started most importantly though
we actually did get a comment on the G+
stream last night from raphael zu Minsky
who I think has a really good question
yes if you have time can you please go
into detail and explain the behavior of
the up navigation versus the back button
in the Play Music app specifically how
is it affected by different entry points
into the app so when you guys get a
chance as you're looking at the action
bar I think a lot of people would would
really like to have a better explanation
of up versus back and happily we have
the right person in the room because
Adam in fact gave a talk about this very
subject at Google i/o this is did he
invent the word affordance you know
willing to take blame slash credit for
affordance no all right
think so so we can definitely go ahead
and include links not only to the design
guide yeah on the topic of up versus
back but also to the talk that we gave
IO for that topic as well I think that
it depending on some of the complex
cases that you can get into it can get
somewhat sophisticated although I think
that there's a few overarching
guidelines that that tend to dominate
cool well it so as we go through some of
these other wraps we'll see whether
there's an opportunity because you're
absolutely right we should we should
move on right and in the interest of
time as well I know that we we're going
to take a look at the tablet UI on some
of these yes but by and large I think
that music apps are really the sort of
app that it used to replace a pocket mp3
player in many cases I mean it's
entirely reasonable to to really focus
on the experience on a phone for a music
app so yeah we'll go ahead and call out
when an application did a particularly
good job of providing a tablet UI in
addition to the phone experience
absolutely in the interest of time maybe
we should we should we should move on
now let's have a look at actually let's
have a look at a few of these together
we'll check out xenoamp xenoamp and
probably xenoamp
at the same time okay I think that makes
sense right there okay cool
so let's let's switch to the phone where
we've cleared data so we can start from
scratch all right perfect
so first off I think that we might have
a bit of a trademark issue on this it
looks like the xenoamp has used the
nexus X for color yes you want to watch
that so maybe choose a different logo
that doesn't quite infringe on another
trademark now let's fire it up okay so
it's warning us that this is an early
version and that we need to turn off our
firewall or disable it for xenoamp yeah
I don't know that that's the first thing
you want to be telling people to inspire
confidence like you know remove security
precautions so that our app can do stuff
I don't know that makes me a little
nervous
slightly schedule although they do have
kind of a nice playful voice to this
with this is true yeah yeah yeah
and this kind of goes throughout the
whole app which are quite nice and so
you know we're gonna go right off the
bat and point out this is clearly an
earlier version so we're gonna you know
it it's definitely some we're going to
look at but you know in line with the
the playful attitude of the developers
we're going to take a similar attitude I
think of looking at this happen and
hopefully you guys will take it in the
spirit it was intended so this is where
we start with militant authentication
failure touch me here stopped so I touch
here and nothing happens
little things lighting up there and I
can see okay there is there was
something we touch and hold here okay
now we've got something that starts to
resemble any UI all right so let go so
we can see what else depressed hmm no
its fading away anyway so the first
thing that I noticed with this app but
not only do they hide the status bar
then they create their own so you know
I've has its own clock and its title
occupying the space where notifications
would normally be along with what looks
to be a battery readout yeah and so okay
so to be clear so we spend a lot of time
and I think I in particular spent some
time online talking about how I hate it
when apps hide the status bar because
you know I use the status bar to see
what time it is see how much battery
I've got left the solution I was looking
for was not to just put the time in the
battery into your own fake status bar I
was kind of just using those as examples
leave the status bar and unless you're
sort of consuming content that's
supposed to be in nurse if there isn't
really no reason to take that away so
there was one exception to that actually
is you'll notice this in a lot of apps
is that if you go to landscape mode
landscape mode you're very constrained
for them vertical real estate so a lot
of times it makes sense to perhaps hide
the status bar in landscape but still
bring it back in portrait so that if the
user needs to get back to their
notification so on and so forth they can
simply rotate the device and get it back
in this case this app offers neither
alright so let's let's continue to touch
see I'm touching the wrong place because
I can't get though there we go so I need
to drive slightly so I need to move in
order to get things and so all right so
again none of these is entirely clear
what I need to do to listen to stuff
your drum user I guess music makes sense
so if I drag down to music then I get
this this kind of wacky display now it's
clear that the whoever's put this
together has some I'm guessing OpenGL
skills but this this list view is kind
of surreal in that sense clearly not a
list view just in the way that it
behaves it doesn't follow the same sort
of fling physics on a fleam physics are
phenomenal it's almost sort of just
accelerate so I start a little and it
straight away shoots up and seems to I
just want to keep going like it's in
some sort of anti-gravity well just kind
of cool and then I can move these things
around but it's not really clear to what
purpose
see where they were disappearing off
screen beforehand which isn't happening
now there I mean it seems that this is
meant to get two different albums within
a certain artists catalogue but why
you're able to scroll this one all of it
would fit on screen and there's only one
album available it's questionable yeah
you're just kind of wondering what is
the you know I'm touching things and
everything's moving and I'm not really
sure why and how oh there I guess so
Jimmy Smith is gone I think we can get
him back that maybe maybe not I guess I
have to come back you know one thing to
notice on the
on that scrolling list view is that
actually does look a lot like what you'd
see with our default physics if you
don't know the magic numbers to plug in
to scale it is that right yeah yeah if
you look at the class that I wrote it on
custom controls you'll actually see that
I had to plug in a couple of magic
numbers that I pulled out of the AOSP
code base to make sure that the physics
scaled correctly and didn't feel like
they were too fast brilliant all right
so was so that's a an Android you class
you've got at C developer.android.com
slash training and it's cold
it is impossible yes something like
building custom views making custom
views cool custom views well paste that
link into the G+ stream I think and
check that out yeah and in the spirit of
a beta we also have our FPS counter up
in the corner that's because probably
can't quite see it but that's what this
number here is which is running at a
pretty decent sort of 29 per dish and so
you actually start scrolling at which
point that still staying up around 30 I
think it's down it's down there here and
there but it's not bad
the tracking performance which is good
absolutely
so let's let's actually navigate in and
try and play an album so we've got this
album it's again everything's kind of
this nice slighty scrolling view it
looks really cool if a little bit
impenetrable in terms of navigation
because we're here now and you know I'm
not really clear where we are there's
not an action bar there's no sort of you
know obvious navigation I can bring up
this weird sort of bottom slider e thing
which is kind of like my navigation
anything and I can move stuff around but
again it's not entirely clear what I'm
doing or why these things are moving so
if we try to drill in on this see
nothing happens in select something so
what you guys can't tell which we can
tell us this is actually failing the
first test of week we can't figure out
how to make it play music pressing this
selecting this is does does nothing
there's no sort of play affordance see I
love that word now wait no no it's here
on a list I think so but I don't know
how to make the playlist play just you
you just said my pet peeve which is
playlist you know I have nothing gets
playlists per se but when you're
required to put something out on lay
list before you freakin play it that's
wrong you shouldn't have to set things
up before you do what the app is meant
to do absolutely this we we discussed
this with podcast players and went nuts
on it then this is even worse absolutely
I totally agree I mean that's it's it
fails that fundamental rule which is you
should be able to start doing whatever
the point of the app is with as few oh
you found a way we started playing music
outstanding how prep now the man's gonna
that's a good cuts off now we have four
seconds how did you do this Adam while
we mean that's a good question emo
talking going management play music
right so I think that the the core issue
around this app is really
discoverability mmm I think that they've
they've got this really interesting UI
that they're that they're putting
together it's something that is clearly
meant to be operated using fingers using
gestures it seems like they might be
onto something really interesting hmm
but you can really end up spending a lot
of time with this app without it being
entirely obvious how to perform basic
functions that you may be familiar with
from other musical's absolutely I think
that's that's kind of the key here and
so and this is something which I think
you know in and myself I have spoken
about and particularly in hopefully
you'll agree with me that you don't have
to make an app which looks like every
other Android app it doesn't have to
have an action bar it doesn't have to
have list views like something like what
they've done here to create something
quite radically different is actually
kind of cool
you know we lock caps which it
innovative and change the way that you
expect things to happen but and music
apps have long been the source of this
sort of innovation absolutely the number
of different operating systems I mean
you can think back to the early 90s
where you had things that look like car
stereos on your desk possibly and so
forth there was a whole spinning
community around Wynn app which no one
nominated this week so we're not going
to look at but that was kind of the
whole point of Wynn app was he could get
all these cool different custom looking
new eyes which is kind of cool so the
letters that were a place to experiment
like this a music or media player app is
is really kind of a great fertile ground
for doing something that I actually feel
like I could find myself totally loving
this app like like it could become my
favorite music player partly just
because I think what they're doing now I
could be wrong but I think what they're
doing with the UI is making it easy to
operate without really looking at it you
know I'm just going to I'm gonna touch
it a really predictable place in the
middle of the screen on a target this is
a tag antic and then I'm just going to
slide my finger one way or the other
right not right now because it's not
working but it seemed like you might be
able to yeah and this is part of the
navigation issue that we see now now the
various things come up and so I guess
that's really it it's just it's like
perhaps we're running into bugs at that
point it could well be you know and I
think you know if that's what you guys
are trying to do I think that's that's
great like and maybe you're just
suffering from that 80/20 rule where
it's 80% of the way there you've got all
the functionality you've got all the
navigation but the 20% that remains to
be done is the bit which makes it
actually impossible to navigate if you
don't know the magic things to press
that's right
and that's why it's really important
that you get people to be to test your
apps and really watch to see how they
use them because I'm sure if the
developer for this app was standing
behind us you'd be like no no no no you
just you just have to press here and
then here why are you pressing over
there why are you dragging that why are
you pressing the back button and that's
our testing is really an illuminating
experience it really behind glass where
they found under glass y-yeah and this
is why test is a really valuable
you know us engineering folks we have
this tendency to know
it works and then do it the right way
and then you put it in front of testers
and they're like trying to press two
buttons at the same time why are you
pressing ok and cancel at the same why
are you pressing ok like 10 times in a
row real quick all these little bits and
pieces when you see people actually
using your app or testing them trying to
break them is how you really get that
next stage polished to something which
people really love and they're excited
about that's right so this app doesn't
claim to be more than a beta at this
point and I think that at this point I
think it's really more of an alpha at
this stage just given that it's it's
just a little too hard to use it's a
little too frustrating I want to see you
guys maybe spend a little bit more time
you know building something that's a
little bit more predictable before you
spend you know too much more effort
getting it out there or at least start
start guiding the user through the first
a little bit more alright let's let's
move on to the next app no I don't have
a none of us have a Spotify account set
up right now yeah we tested this on some
other devices previously yeah and
Spotify in general given that we were
running out of time a little bit here I
think it's probably a reasonable one to
skip it's grayed out fantastic
functionality in a pretty decent UI and
they've actually worked pretty well in
terms of getting some of the newest
features integrated things like widgets
and Universal Search they were building
those sorts of things straight in off
the bat so do check out Spotify it's
it's pretty cool but we're gonna we're
gonna skip past that one of the other
things that we would want to highlight
and Spotify as well is that they do use
the ever emerging pattern of the side
drawer that slides out from one side so
I believe that the most recent update to
the Android design guide is words to say
about that it does so definitely go
check that out of your interest yet
that's the big tip so yeah definitely if
you are interested in the draw pattern
do check out the new design site update
it has a whole section on that the too
long didn't read version is the way the
YouTube app does it is pretty much
spot-on so if you do want to know what's
the right way to implement that that's
probably the right place to start some
looking to overhype
powered by the hyper machine there is a
lot of hype going on here
so yeah again so this passes the test of
straightaway you start off the app you
have a list of music you press a music
track and it actually does start playing
and it starts playing music which is
perfect it's exactly what what you want
from an app from a music playing out if
we go to the home screen we can go down
here
I think that's yeah that's it we can
navigate there unfortunately there's no
ability control the playback from the
notification which is a bit of a
disappointment about the lockscreen it's
try the lockscreen
let's try the lock screen again there
does nice so they have the lock screen -
wait a second was the same song we know
I believe this was from one of our
earlier apps I think that we still have
ones that say no amp or one of the other
ones could be one of the other ones
which is already clear these out just
just to make sure that we're set here
yeah
so good actually of a high love a
notification sitting up in there for hmm
interesting
alright we may need to be a little bit
more aggressive for that one all right
nonetheless oh that's another app which
is behaving a little bit less politely
yeah yeah so the muse is there so
unfortunately they're not on the
lockscreen but it does mean that they
are probably not using the audio focus
quite correctly because I should clear
out any other app that's playing that's
right let's just go ahead and kill this
to be sure here though so what's
confusing it's what's playing on the
tablet yeah it was anyway yeah so nice
works ni upon on having the lock screen
controls okay
so testing once again we don't envy that
Havelock's oh I have a so hopeful wait
does it happen when we're playing
perhaps maybe that helps have a look no
okay so that's fine you can you can
heart things here which is nice well
theoretically so you need to be a member
of your team for that and actually this
is a pattern that I actually quite like
it's nothing gets hidden nothing gets
removed if you try and do something
which requires a membership then you
point it out and give people the
opportunity right now wait until the
last minute before you actually require
that login so that people can really
make that informed decision of whether
or not they want to take that step and
create an account for your service
thanks I I am gonna make one I've got
one thing to say though about the heart
button shouldn't that be a star button
well you know it probably should to it
but I guess it kind of depends on what
they mean by by the heart buttons right
if it's if they're favoriting something
for their own sake then I think star is
a much better metaphor but if they are
sort of liking it as in promoting it to
their friends or something which they
are enjoying then heart it kind of
almost makes more sense by the way I
noticed that when we're doing this top
to bottom thing and it totally doesn't
work to have us looking left to right I
think well yeah what we want is to be
like this like Brady Bunch style what do
you think right now how's it going this
is weird hey nice love it yeah I'm just
saying that you know you don't get to
pick your favorite you know Lucky Charms
metaphor too you know there's a there's
a star for for making something your
favorite and the heart means you know
kind of nothing to the average Android
user sure so something for something
that ties into an existing service if
you already have a metaphor for doing
perform an action like this then
sometimes it makes sense to stay
consistent with the rest of that
services that is a really good point
yeah so we see that in this screen we
actually have a menu button a shame
is there it does nothing just
particularly weird because we've kind of
got this action bar type our metaphor
and while we're here we'll also we'll
see what happens when we hit the share
button that we get the sharing apps
which is nice so that's happy making now
what's a little bit weirder is this icon
here which I have no idea what that
means sort of filter but no it's it's an
overflow you would normally expect yes
it's kind of a right-to-left overflow
now it's it's weird because if we've got
an overflow that what we don't need the
menu button on the bottom right and if
we goes also another example of non
standard action bar yet as well
absolutely using just a little bit of a
different size for everything a little
bit different metrics yeah that stands
out and if we go back to the to the main
menu then we find out that here the menu
button isn't a button of shame but it is
confusing because everything in this is
just as appropriate when you listening
to a track as it is when you're
listening to when you're looking at a
list of tracks and we do have one of
your favourite actions exit button yay
no there's no need for an exit button
for a music playing app as soon as you
were paused that should be the
equivalent of everything stopped you
shouldn't have any services running
there shouldn't be any difference at
that point for between hitting exit or
just hitting back that should be
equivalent and so then there's no need
to put it in there because again as soon
as you have an exit button I understand
that some users like an exit button and
that it's a nice thing to put in there
but it's totally ambiguous it's
meaningless you don't no one actually
knows what that exit button is going to
do so putting it there is just runs the
risk of frustrating your users and
annoying the hell out of me let's go
back in here yeah a splash screen every
time we start up again is that really
necessary like we're not reticulating
splines here you should just be able to
start off and have these things cached
so that we get a nice clean quick start
up every time although I do have to say
that if you are loading something for
the first time showing something a
little bit more attractive than a
loading spinner I think yeah I think so
I think the first time you load you want
to have something and we have sort of
preferences around how much time you
should be showing a blank screen I
no time so definitely having a splash
screen or a loading screen the first
time is nice but everything after the
first time I feel like you should
already have that data cached in a way
that you should be able to bring backup
quick and just to run through a couple
of other things very quickly before we
move on you'll notice that we do have
the top tabs here to move between some
different elements but we don't actually
have the ability to swipe between these
we do have a sort of a long press action
presented and a nicer way than your
standard screen along so as you flip
between here we do get a short period of
loading before bringing up bit of
pre-caching here would be nice as well
there's a good chance that you can hit
these top actions so one after you've
loaded the first one and nothing else
was happening just pretty load him in
the background it's gonna be really
relatively cheap and if this was
something that sits in a viewpager then
suddenly the loaders attached to
different fragments make that very easy
to implement so forth so the other thing
that kind of shows with this as well is
we have this bottom strip on each one of
these pages as well it's kind of like a
second set of tabs kind of not is a is
it more of a filter is it from different
sources we can go for Twitter over here
as well so this is something that always
kind of bothers me in apps when you try
to to sandwich different levels of
hierarchy on opposite sides of the
content I think that it makes it more
difficult to tell where you're drilling
down into that hierarchy so on and so
forth and then this happened
particularly you have a very small touch
target for these bottom tabs that sits
right next to the capacitive buttons for
navigation even on devices that don't
use the soft navigation hmm a couple of
other points really quickly before we
jump onto the lightning round for the
last two apps in two minutes we're using
a non-standard font here and our Romans
not here so you can't go on at length
about typography it's a nice font but it
is a little disconcerting maybe just
having that that different font style
here I don't know that it entirely works
but it looks like it may be a part of
their brand for the rest of the lovely
we would have to dig a little bit deeper
into that yeah and the very last thing I
want to say is that what's not clear to
me as a music listener is where this
music is coming from and what the rights
are for them so it seems like someone is
blogging about them you know I'm very
conscious of not wanting to to pirate
music when there's plenty of sources I
can use to get it for free I have
absolutely no idea what the scenario is
here but that's kind of the point is it
would be nice to have some better idea
of exactly how this music is coming to
be on my phone or how it's going to be
available to me if I get on an airplane
exactly alright so lightning round we've
got our amp and player pro which both
have very similar icon stylings and as
it turns out fairly similar
functionality so we'll start with power
amp real quick so power aims been a
longtime favorite of a lot of others
around the office here and once you
start digging into it it becomes really
easy to see why so they seem to stick
with a lot of Android conventions just
to keep you familiar with basic
functionality you've got what not quite
an action bar but very similar here you
know the metrics are a little bit off it
looks like this this may actually be an
action bar of the hood with some some
other modifications to it I'd have to
look a little bit closer in certain but
the convention is there so exactly look
for that as soon as you start pressing
on the screen you can sort of it shows
that these are bars that these are
things that you can press and you get
the little help texts and things as well
absolutely she's really nice so this was
a great feature as well is this ability
to just swipe between tracks mmm
so this totally totally makes my in the
car experience work in that you know if
I want to skip a track it's just a swipe
but I need to look at it I need to find
the fast-forward key I just swipe in the
middle of the screen that's right if we
hit play okay it's not changing the
volume which is nice if we actually find
out here we can see that it does have
controls in the in the notification
which is excellent
and I don't know if it has it in the it
unfortunately it doesn't have it in the
Oh Jim Jim mentions that you actually do
need to enable the lock screen controls
in the SATs right we did in fact
discover that or at least Adam did right
this is the sort of thing where it'd be
really great if the app detected what
version of the platform it'd be running
on and just automatically enabled this
by default but the fact that it is there
it still gets points exactly so that's
great but this it doesn't seem like
there's a good reason not to have that
as a default action I'd actually be
quite curious to know from the
developer's perspective why that is you
know why not default it to on given that
you can detect what version of Android
you're running on yeah it seems to be
that they have some other functionality
to enable controls on the lockscreen
previous versions the platform as well
so it may have been a matter of trying
to keep your settings as migrated so
it's not - that would thing centers so
maybe it's just a simple case of
checking to see whether it's an upgrade
or not and then defaulting your uh your
options that way thanks true we have
some really nice options here we're not
going to go into too much depth but
really pretty controls for the equalizer
and in fact you know bass treble volume
the whole thing in fact if you go back
oh it doesn't so maybe it's just in
landscape version it has this nice
effect at least I thought that it did of
showing the equalizer in the action bar
I can't get that to come up right now oh
I think that was if you run it on a
tablet maybe that's one of the other
apps that provides some interesting
functionality on a tablet as well cool
so media we are totally out of time so
I'm not getting into any more detail
here but generally speaking this is a
really nice looking out great
functionality does pretty much
everything that we asked it to in terms
of what a music player should do so yeah
nicely done and most of all I really
want to call this out as well is that
power amp end tune wiki on its list of
songs as well you can really tell that
they spent spent time optimizing and
made sure that the entire experience was
very smooth absolutely so really
polished really nicely done
now I know that our engineer is going to
get yeah it's gonna get really nervous
if we don't wrap up soon because we're
not gonna have any time for for the team
at the Friday game review to get started
so we're going to put a hold on player
Pro and see if we can maybe get a chance
to look at that at another point but
absolutely so far we're really happy
with most of the apps we looked at today
I think there's some some really
polished experiences and and some you
know interesting up and comers
definitely some interesting perspectives
on the genre and what was really great
is that all these apps really took a
different approach to playing music I
mean you don't see a lot of clone
functionality between those apps very
true we didn't even have to go and pick
and choose different things that was
just by virtue of what was on the front
page on moderator speaking of which next
week we're going to be looking at
football apps in celebration of the
beginning of the NFL season here in the
US so if you have a football app of any
kind please do not eat it in the
moderator so that the team can check it
out next week we're also going to try
and start in integrating interviews with
some of the developers of some of these
apps probably a week afterwards so
anyone who has you know been reviewed on
the Friday app clinic or the Friday app
review which came beforehand do drop us
a line if you're interested in talking
through some of your decisions or in
fact if you've made any changes that
you'd like to share with us all and
we'll see if we can get you on a hangout
in now one of the next few weeks to talk
it over in the meantime thank you guys
very much for tuning in thank you Adam
for joining us this week thank you in
for producing the show you're welcome in
don't forget to stick around for the
brand new Friday game review starring
Dan Galpin and new co-host Co Kim
outstanding that should should be a good
one so and thank you to Daniel for our
engineering as always and we'll see you
guys all next week